[Music]
all right so as we be expected from fake
new CNN Brooke Baldwin and Don Lemon are
now defending and trying to normalize
the left's mob behavior take a look at
this when you see people like Ted Cruz
getting chased out of restaurants by a
mob you're not gonna use the my word oh
it's it's totally a mob it is without a
doubt there's no other word Atlas it's a
stop that is mob we already did that we
already said they weren't mobs no it's
not Marvel hey babe yes it's people who
are upset and they're angry with the way
the way the country is going and the
policies please before you jump in okay
all right here with reaction author of
the New York Times bestseller
Trump's America the truth about our
nation's great comeback the only person
really talking about it Fox News
contributor former Speaker of the House
Newt Gingrich all right so we're 27 days
an election day we watched three weeks
of just the abandonment of any due
process and presumption of innocence
then you've got Sarah Sanders Pam Bondi
secretary Neilson Senator McConnell Cruz
they're being chased out of restaurants
Hillary Clinton says we cannot as
Democrats be civil and Eric Holder is
saying when they go low kick them
meaning political opposition will this
work in 27 days is that their strategy
well I mean what you see is the
emergence in a very weird way of a brown
shirt party to use the term for the
people who and via our Germany went out
and literally dominated the streets by
brute force they can't win they didn't
win in the Senate they didn't win in the
presidency in my judgment they're not
going to win on Election Day
and they're becoming more hysterical
more anti-democratic more willing to
destroy the system Abraham Lincoln
warned that there are people who oppose
us so much that it is either their way
or they destroy it and I think that
we're faced with
that kind of opposition so I mean let's
have an open public debate if you think
people like Eric Holder Hillary Clinton
should be allowed to impose their will
by brute violence then you want to go
Democrat if you think that's profoundly
wrong then you're Deveaux Republican we
now have Rasmussen today Republicans now
lead Democrats pretty healthy margin in
terms of enthusiasm and what was just
maybe two months ago a huge gap in terms
of generic ballot it's now dead even
according to Rasmussen so there's been a
dramatic shift here so going forward the
next 27 days you're a great strategist a
great historian what do Republican
candidates Senate and House need to say
and do to win oh god I think Majority
Leader Kevin McCarthy has given us a
perfect example of the kind of campaign
we need to wage in the next few weeks
McCarthy's introduced a bill which
basically says if you want to stop
fentanyl from killing your children if
you want to stop car fentanyl which is
even worse from killing your children if
you want to stop ms-13 from terrorizing
your neighborhood if you want to stop
human trafficking we have to control the
southern border now the other side says
the Democrats say no no we need open
borders sanctuary cities abolish ice
well let's have a referendum everybody
who thinks we don't have enough crime in
America we don't have enough drugs in
America we don't have enough violence in
America vote Democrat everybody thinks
that Kevin McCarthy is right and we need
to control the border and get back to a
point where our children our
neighborhoods are safe vote Republican
are we better off as a country in terms
of our security than we were two years
ago is the economy by every measure
better off I think we know the answer
it's interesting you are my radio show
today and I mentioned in California
where Gavin Newsom you would think is up
by 20 points it's now almost within the
margin of error John Cox a businessman
is running against them this is now a
sanctuary state and he's offering health
care to everybody
every one that means legal illegal the
the highly taxed the high level of
Taxation out in California
it puts it open basically anybody gets
sick at America go out to California
they'll take care of you look I just
want to share with the audience who
knows how close you and I have been for
all these years you blew me away on the
radio show today I mean I was standing
there going oh my god this is a whole
new way of thinking about it because
you're right
basically the way that the Democrats
have set it up in California if you're
in Tennessee or New York or Texas and
you had a serious disease gavin newsom
sending or signal come to california and
let us pay for it will contain every
governor that they can be audibly
campaigning for you
then we campaigning for Newsome because
you know they have a chance here to send
every sick person in their state to
California and let new some good now if
I were Californian I would think that
was insane but you backed it up today I
had never thought about the domestic
side of that and you're exactly right
well that's what they're saying you
don't even have to be a resident
thirteen and a half percent state income
tax out in California right now it's
gonna be higher all right mr. speaker
2700 news I think under Newsom under
Newsom against the 25 that's my
prediction okay five percent income tax
all right 27 days to go mr. speaker
we'll have you on a lot between now and
then thank you for being with us